les magistrats de la Cour des comptes
qui ont participé à l'élaboration du
rapport relatif à la mise en oeuvre du
brexit en France publié le 14 juin
dernier je salue et remercie pour leur
présence Monsieur Jean-Pierre
labourecque conseiller maître président
de la formation interchange de la Cour
des comptes relative à la préparation à
la mise en œuvre du brexit en France
madame français Bouillard conseiller à
remettre présidente de section à la
première chambre de la Cour des comptes
et contre rapporteur et Monsieur Denis
tercen conseiller maître à la première
chambre de la Cour des comptes et
rapporteur général nous avons lu avec
grande intention votre rapport et prix
connaissance de vos constats et
recommandations sur des sujets qui nous
mobilisent depuis 7 ans maintenant
dès le référendum britannique approuvant
le brexit notre commission avec la
commission des Affaires étrangères a mis
en place un groupe de suivi dont je
salue les membres présents ici mais ici
nous avons des membres de la commission
des affaires européennes essentiellement
ce groupe s'est attaché à suivre les
enjeux liés à la sortie du Royaume-Uni
de l'Union européenne et ses
conséquences notamment pour notre pays
une délégation du groupe de suivi
c'était d'ailleurs rendu dès le 6
janvier 2021 à Calais et à
Boulogne-sur-Mer pour constater sur le
terrain les conséquences du
rétablissement d'une frontière
extérieure de l'Union européenne avec le
Royaume-Uni nous nous étions alors
rendus sur le site de rotunnel ainsi
qu'aux port de Calais et avions
rencontré des représentants de la
filière pêche à Boulogne j'avais
quelques semaines plus tard déposé avec
mon collègue Christian Cambon président
de la commission des affaires étrangères
une proposition de résolution européenne
sur la proposition de règlement de la
Commission européenne qui visait alors à
instaurer une réserve d'ajustement au
brexit
nous avions ainsi proposé d'apporter un
certain nombre de modifications au
fonctionnement de cette réserve afin
qu'elle permette une plus juste
compensation des conséquences négatives
du retrait du Royaume-Uni sur l'économie
des États membres et notamment de la
France nous avions été entendus puisque
le gouvernement français a réussi dans
les négociations à obtenir une
augmentation de l'enveloppe pour notre
pays et un assouplissement des
conditions d'exécution nous sommes
rapidement inquiétés du déploiement
effectif de cette enveloppe budgétaire
obtenue de haute lutte sur laquelle
l'État a tenu à garder la main la région
des Hauts-de-France dont je suis élu
mais alerté de plus en plus fortement
sur les difficultés de mise en oeuvre de
cette réserve c'est pourquoi j'ai lu
avec attention et stupeur votre rapport
qui indique que la France n'envisage
d'utiliser que 31,5% de l'enveloppe les
736 millions d'euros qui lui a été
alloué vous pointez des défaillances
dans l'organisation et le portage
interministériel qu'en est-il
comment expliquer une telle
sous-utilisation des crédits quels
seront les entreprises et les secteurs
qui pourront finalement bénéficier de
cette réserve qui je le rappelle
fonctionne par un système de
remboursement expost des dépenses
engagées qui sont éligibles toujours sur
la question financière j'aimerais
revenir sur la situation des pêcheurs
selon le comité scientifique technique
et économique dépêche les pertes direct
liées aux réductions de quotas de pêche
du fait de la sortie du Royaume-Uni
représenté 3 millions d'euros en 2021 et
devrait augmenter pour atteindre 6,2
millions d'euros en 2025 comme vous le
comme vous le mentionnez dans votre
rapport la Direction Générale des
Affaires maritimes et des pêches ainsi
constaté que les navires dépendants à
50% des eaux britanniques subissaient en
moyenne une perte de 30% de leur chiffre
d'affaires par rapport à 2019
vous relevez néanmoins dans l'annexe de
au rapport que l'indemnisation des
pertes de chiffres d'affaires des
entreprises de pêche affectées par le
brexit a été très peu sollicitée puisque
seul 12 entreprises de pêche ont été
indemnisées pour 580.000 euros et quatre
entreprises de mariage pour 240000 euros
alors qu'un budget de 20 millions
d'euros était prévu comment expliquer ce
décalage est-il dû au défaillance de la
gestion de la réserve d'ajustement du
brexit et à qui finalement les imputer
sur la question plus générale du
rétablissement de la frontière vous
indiquez dans votre rapport que celle-ci
s'est faite sans difficulté majeure et
dans le temps notamment grâce au reports
successifs de l'accord et la crise
sanitaire qui a induit une diminution
des échanges vous pointez néanmoins des
progrès à effectuer s'agissent en
notamment du système d'information
brexit pourriez-vous nous en dire plus
enfin je souhaitais vous interroger sur
le poste de contrôle
frontalier parlant pardon de
Boulogne-sur-Mer la Commission
européenne a autorisé ce poste à titre
dérogatoire et expérimental à réaliser
les contrôles sans être situés à un
point de passage frontalier de l'Union
européenne dans votre rapport vous
relevez les difficultés récurrentes
rencontrées par ceux post et vous
préconisez un audit complet afin d'y
remédier pensez-vous que ces difficultés
puissenter en conduire la Commission à
remettre en cause cette expérimentation
et quel serait finalement les
conséquences d'une telle décision
je vous remercie par avance pour les
réponses que vous apporterez à mes
questions j'ai également d'autres
questions quelquefois peut-être aussi
des suggestions de réponse mais il
laisserait naturellement mes collègues
posées d'abord leur propre question
après votre présentation et je vous aide
désormais la parole
pour cette introduction ces questions
auxquelles j'apporterai quelques
éléments de réponse vous avez présenté
en effet l'équipe c'était une formation
interchante qui regroupait trois
chambres différentes
la première chambre dont nous faisons
partie mais aussi
la chambre en charge des questions de
sécurité la chambre en charge et
question d'agriculture et de pêche ce
qui nous permettait d'avoir eu une vue
d'ensemble donc nous avons engagé cette
enquête dans le courant de l'année 2022
amis 2022 donc un peu plus de deux ans
après la sortie effective du Royaume-Uni
le 31 janvier 2020 un peu plus d'un an
après l'accord de commerce et de
coopération du 1er janvier 2021 nous
nous sommes centrés sur quelques
questions sur ce sujet très large il
fallait
se centrer sur quelques points sauf à ce
père sur l'ensemble des politiques
communautaires en particulier nous
sommes centrés sur l'organisation des
administrations
bon rétablissement de la frontière les
effets du brexit sur les entreprises et
citoyens et l'accompagnement de l'État
et dans un troisième point les
conditions d'application des accords les
risques de divergences réglementaires
donc nous nous n'avons pas abordé
certains points le processus de
négociation communautaire nous ne
qualifions pas les décisions
britanniques pour nous c'est une donnée
nous avons constaté à Douvres par
exemple des difficultés qui
lèvent pas en premier lieu des autorités
françaises mais nous ne qualifions pas
nous constatons c'est tout nous n'allons
pas non plus dans le détail de questions
bilatérales de police d'immigration de
justice de défense sur la politique de
la pêche nous ne sommes pas rentrés non
plus dans le détail par exemple des
négociations sur les licences de pêche
alors le point de départ de ce brexit
en 2019 le Royaume-Uni est un partenaire
économique majeur c'est notre première
excédent bilatérale presque 13 milliards
avec des secteurs très forts c'est un
très grand marché pour les biens
6e client de la France 8e fournisseur
35 milliards d'exportation 2019 c'est un
partenaire essentiel en matière de
service puisque c'est notre deuxième
marché à l'exportation ou à
l'importation et peut-être plus
important encore c'est une réalité pour
beaucoup d'entreprises françaises c'est
un peu plus de 30 000 entreprises
françaises qui exportaient avant de
brexit et beaucoup de PME près de 80%
moins de moins de 50 salariés et les
importateurs de l'ordre 200 000
importateurs là aussi parfois pour des
montants
relativement peu importante donc c'est
une réalité dans le tissu économique
français alors le premier thème que nous
avons regardé c'est
ce rétablissement de la frontière pour
aboutir un message que il y a encore des
transformations à poursuivre cette
frontière
remet en cause les quatre libertés
fondamentales du marché unique la libre
circulation des biens des personnes des
services des capitaux et donc tout cela
des conséquences majeures sur toute une
série de secteurs
une fine et se rétablissement de la
frontière s'est fait sans difficulté
majeures en janvier 2021 c'était un
véritable défi organisé organisationnel
l'organisation interministérielle s'est
révélée réactive le secrétaire général
aux Affaires européennes la direction de
l'Union européenne au Quai d'Orsay la
Représentation permanente à Bruxelles la
direction du Trésor était parmi les
administrations les plus impliquées et
bien entendu les administrations de la
frontière les opérateurs
d'infrastructures
ce sont coordonnées pour arriver à ce
résultat des circonstances particulières
ont permis on facilité cette mise en
oeuvre finalement dont de bonnes
conditions ce sont les reports
successifs liés au rebondissements de
cette négociation que nous avons tous
suivi tout cela durait un peu plus de
quatre ans et puis la crise sanitaire a
eu aussi des effets sur les volumes
d'échanges qui finalement au moment où
l'on basculait au rétablissement de la
frontière à faciliter les choses alors
la première administration concernait la
douane
elle a mis en place un nouveau
dispositif ce qu'elle appelle la
frontière intelligente qui repose sur
l'anticipation l'identification
l'automatisation des contrôles un
nouveau système d'information appelé le
si brexit a été mise en œuvre Capgemini
a contribué ça a été internalisé ensuite
au sein de la Direction des douanes
c'était opérationnel dès 2021 la
disponibilité a été assurée nous avons
fait un audit de ce système
d'information et nous n'avons pas relevé
de critiques de
importante à faire sur le caractère
opérationnel de ce système d'information
il y a quelques progrès encore à faire
dans les échanges d'informations avec
d'autres services de la frontière de
service vétérinaire ne vous ont une
recommandation et des progrès sur un
point assez technique l'appariement des
données nous paraissent possible la
douane est prête considérer cette
évolution elle a bénéficié pour arriver
à ce résultat un être renforcement de
ses moyens cette sans création d'emplois
jusqu'en 2021 et par déploiement un peu
plus de 100 emplois ont été dégagés sur
la période la plus récente donc la
douane est évidemment en première ligne
sur tout ce qui est flux de marchandises
et on constate un retour progressif
une situation on va dire proche de la
normale même si tout au début il y a eu
des comportements de sur stockage fin
2020 qui ont affecté les flux de
marchandises début 2021 point important
c'est que la place de la France a été
préservée comme point d'entrée de tous
ces flux et petite carte des ports les
plus concernés rappelle cette cette
réalité deuxième administration de la
frontière la plus concernée c'est le
mystère de l'agriculture avec son
service d'inspection vétérinaire et
phytosanitaire
il y a des progrès d'organisation à voir
c'est un service qui a complètement
changé de dimension il y avait un peu
moins de 100 personnes
UTP enfin poste budgétaire en 2019 il a
fallu recruter près de 400 personnes
chiffres ami 2022 avec des difficultés
de recrutement d'encadrement liés à la
technicité de ces métiers
parfois délocalisations
tout ça pour arriver à en termes
d'activité à des contrôles sanitaires
qui sont à peu près stabilisés désormais
un niveau moyen que retrace le graphique
alors de notre point de vue cette
organisation doit être améliorée
il faut mieux tenir compte de la réalité
des flux à contrôler
5 contrôles postes de contrôle
frontaliers ont été créés ce qui porte
de trois à huit le nombre de de contrôle
frontaliers avec une compétence
vétérinaire et phytosanitaire les places
les plages horaires sont très larges
certains postes sont surdimensionnés au
regard de la réalité des flux à
contrôler
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
recommandons à réexamen de
l'organisation de ces temps de travail
voire dans un ou deux cas peut-être
reposer la question de l'existence même
de ces postes de contrôle
vétérinaires et phytosanitaire et vous
l'avez signalé nous avons pointé sur le
cas de Boulogne-sur-Mer des questions
d'organisation on y reviendra tout à
l'heure dans les questions-réponses
ça c'était pour les flux de bien de
marchandises sur les passagers il faut
avoir à l'esprit que les flux de
passagers
jusqu'en 2022 ne sont pas revenus au
niveau de la vente brexit le point bas
était en 2020 en 2022 ça n'est qu'une
reprise partielle
on peut l'illustrer au point de passage
frontaliers des Hauts de France en 2021
un tiers
les flux de passagers c'était un tiers
de la situation 2019 à 7 millions 4
comparé 21 millions cinq et ceux les
tunnels sous la Manche les passagers
circulent circulant 2022 c'est 75% de la
situation 2019 donc on voit que sur les
les mouvements de personnes le brexit a
un effet significatif alors ça concerne
évidemment troisième administration
concernée la police aux frontières
de ce point de vue là nous considérons
que il y a des questions de meilleur
passager à promouvoir
les contrôles de fait ont été allongés
c'est de l'ordre d'un doublement des
temps de contrôle puisque le Royaume-Uni
est désormais un pays tiers des moyens
ont été mis en face 260 créations
d'emplois au point de passage frontalier
ont été obtenus la réalité des
recrutements ont été inférieurs au
contenu des priorités du ministère
intérieur 141 recrutements avaient été
effectués à l'été 2022 à noter un
recours nouveau contractuel sur
le premier niveau de contrôle avec des
assistantes contrôle aux frontières nous
allons constaté que certains pics de
fréquentation méritaient d'être mieux
anticipées alors ces côtés anglais au
moment des vacances scolaires il y a eu
des congestions vraiment très
importantes côté anglais mais côté
français nous n'avons pas non plus été
totalement exemplaire en juillet 2022
lors d'incidents techniques comme en
août 2022 on a pu constater des
difficultés ponctuelles à noter un sujet
particulier en grande masse financière
pas considérable mais du point de vue du
droit qui pose question c'est les droits
de chancellerie
au delà une certaine durée de séjour des
ormelles des citoyens britanniques sont
redevables d'un droit et l'organisation
est totalement inadaptée pour percevoir
ses droits de chancellerie et de fait il
y a une 200 endroits qui ont été perçus
enfin c'est totalement confidentiel il
faut s'organiser pour percevoir
ses droits qui sont organisés désormais
par la législation ça c'était le premier
grand thème le rétablissement de la
frontière les flux de personnes de
marchandises les trois administrations
deuxième sujet que nous avons regardé
plus précisément ce sont les
conséquences du brexit sur les
entreprises et les citoyens et bien tout
ça n'est pas neutre tout ça a des
conséquences direct pour les entreprises
ce sont des coûts des délais avec leur
établissement des formalités et le
libre-échange n'est pas l'absence de
formalités même si c'est un accord sans
droit d'eau à nicotta c'est le retour
des procédures administratives dans les
deux sens à l'exportation comme un
importation avec la nécessité de passer
par exemple par un représentant de
ouagaré
nous avons rencontré les équipes des
rapporteurs des entreprises de taille
diverses ce sont les PME qui ne
travaillaient pas avant sur des pays
tiers qui sont les plus concernés les
exemples que nous avons pu voir ce sont
des des surcos de l'ordre de qui peuvent
atteindre 10% du chiffre d'affaires
parfois
et le cas particulier de la pêche que
vous avez évoqué avec des pertes très
importantes vous les avez évoqué les
chiffres il y a les mariilleurs aussi
très concernés et les navires évidemment
vous avez rappelé des chiffres alors
tout ça se traduit sur le commerce
extérieur en rétablit pas une frontière
on ne rend pas les mouvements de
bien ou de service plus difficile sans
conséquence et donc nous ce qu'on
constate sur 2021 2022 c'est que ça
affecte les exportations françaises au
Royaume-Uni
la relation commerciale avec le
Royaume-Uni étant retrait alors que la
relation commerciale de la France avec
l'Union européenne a poursuivi sa
progression donc on peut l'illustrer les
exportations françaises aux NRJ de
source douanes sont en diminution en
2022 par rapport à 2019
2,4%, là où les exportations
des autres pays européens sont positifs
voire très positives
et puis en matière de service le
tourisme est important on a constaté que
les retours des touristes britanniques
étaient moins que celui en provenance
d'autres pays voisins vers la France
donc ça a eu un effet sur le commerce
extérieur en 2021 et 2022 et ce qui nous
amène à poser la question de
l'accompagnement par les pouvoirs
publics que nous donnons un certain
nombre d'exemples on peut elles sont
elles ont été actives
toute une série de structures
administratives ont pris des initiatives
en tout cas la réserve d'ajustement
brexit en effet de ce point de vue là
n'a pas été utilisé à la hauteur des
attentes et comme vous l'avez rappelé il
y a une négociation pour obtenir un si
vous permettez entre guillemets un bon
chiffre avec 736 millions d'euros sur 2
milliards 5 mais l'organisation
intermittérielle a été de longue à se
mettre en place les décaissements
encore plus et finalement le résultat
des courses c'est que sur ces 736
millions nous allons vers une
consommation de 232 millions d'euros ce
chiffre a été notifié à la Commission de
Bruxelles donc c'est l'estimation la
plus récente elle a été notifiée au
printemps c'est tout récent
et dans ces chiffres là on constate vous
êtes inquiété sur le secteur de la pêche
la prévision est de dépenser ce qui
était prévu dans l'enveloppe initiale
pour le secteur pêche en revanche le
secteur des entreprises ou
400 millions étaient envisagés la
réalité c'est que les entreprises ont
pris leur disposition beaucoup plus
rapidement que ce que permettait les
conditions administratives de cette
réserve et donc elle n'est que très très
peu utilisé et donc 70% de cette
enveloppe 500 millions va être déployé
c'est pas de l'argent perdu mais c'est
de redéployer vers un autre programme
récent qui a été mise en place récemment
au niveau de l'Union européenne dans le
secteur enfin en lien avec la crise
énergétique il faut noter que ces
sous-exécutions ne sont pas propres à la
France on le constat dans toute une
série d'autres pays et donc dans la
construction de cette réserve il y avait
des contraintes qui ont pesé aussi sur
d'autres sur d'autres pays en tout cas
en France
cette réserve sur laquelle beaucoup
d'espoir étaient fondés n'a pas été
utilisé
à l'auteur de ce qui était prévu en sens
inverse du côté positif
on note nous prenons l'exemple du
secteur financier des effets positifs de
ce brexit
avec la fin du passeport européen pour
la City et donc il y a eu une vraie
stratégie d'ensemble Christian Noyer
ancien gouverneur Banque de France mais
les régulateurs aussi ont pris des
dispositions sans d'ailleurs remettre en
cause la réalité de leur contrôle
c'était une facilité
des contacts les agences évidemment
d'attractivité ont joué le rôle en cas
de juridique a été adapté en particulier
avec les impatriés à noter même si
infinie ça s'est joué par tirage au sort
que l'Autorité bancaire européenne a été
installé à Paris alors c'est un
renforcement
limité à l'échelle d'une économie mais
c'est réel pour la place financière donc
l'estimation était de l'ordre de 3000
emplois supplémentaires
à l'été dernier estimation du Trésor
pardon
qui est revu qui a été revu à là aussi
hier ou avant-hier par le cabinet
sans pouvoir l'affirmer parce que ces
questions de
ces emplois sont mobiles ont
affirmé mais en tout cas la France a été
un des grands bénéficiaires de ces
relocalisations d'emplois financiers et
peut-être la première bénéficiaire de
ces relocalisations pour les autres
investissements hors secteur financiers
là aussi des projets
ont été
installés liés directement au brexit
donc sur les 600 projets
retracés par business France entre 2017
et 2021 240 projets avaient le brexit
comme motivation principale
s'agissant
désormais des citoyens ce que nous avons
constaté c'est que des facilités
d'organisation avec des mises en place
des deux côtés de la Manche pour les
résidents donc les systèmes du 7e stage
côté Royaume-Uni les titres de séjour
accorderait du côté des résidents
britanniques en France
les rapporteurs sont allés en Dordogne à
émettre pour constater tout cela et
ça n'a pas eu d'effets de il y a pas eu
de départ
massif ces dispositions ont permis
une certaine stabilité de la population
britannique en France en revanche là
nous l'avons constaté ce qu'on nous
appelons les nouveaux venus au
Royaume-Uni là ça des effets parfois
spectaculaires sur les voyages scolaires
les étudiants les jeunes professionnels
avec
les volontés internationaux entreprises
qui étaient un dispositif magnifique qui
marchait très fort à Londres depuis sa
création des musées 2000 il y a 8000
jeunes qui ont bénéficié de ce
dispositif à Londres maintenant ça
devient presque confidentiel donc que
c'est tellement visible que ça a été un
des points du sommet franco-britannique
du 10 mars 2023 il y a clairement
matière à essayer d'améliorer
d'améliorer les choses dans la relation
bilatérale
tout cela nous amène au troisième sujet
troisième thème l'avenir on va dire et
en fait notre message c'est que le
brexit n'est pas terminé la mise en
oeuvre du brexit est inachevée et il
faut rester vigilant en particulier sur
les dynamiques de divergence
règlementaires alors on voit qu'il y a
trois dynamiques qui sont en jeu la
première c'est que dans son organisation
la mise en oeuvre du brexit il y a
encore des étapes devant nous il y a des
formalités Britanniques à la frontière
par exemple pour les marchandises qui ne
sont pas encore complètement stabilisés
il y a un nouveau dispositif en cours de
déploiement ça ne le sera que
dernières informations d'ici fin 2023
peut-être début 2024 en tout cas
l'équivalent de la frontière
intelligente française de 2021 ne sera
déployé complètement côté britannique
que au mieux fin 2023 il y a des régimes
transitoires qui ont été organ disait
par l'accord de commerce et de
coopération en matière de pêche
évidemment vous avez pointé ce point
avec une date importante au 30 juin 2026
le marché européen de l'énergie aussi
des questions d'accès là aussi 30 juin
2026 il y a des clauses de rendez-vous
pour une évaluation conjointe 5 ans
après il y a des sujets spécifiques je
pense aux chambres de compensation
britannique dans l'Union européenne
c'est tout ce qui est réglement
livraison c'est des sujets très
importants en matière financière en
particulier pour les produits dérivés la
Commission souhaiterait relocaliser ces
chambres de compensation sur le
territoire européen il y a une
équivalence temporaire jusqu'à la
mi-2025 et puis
là où finalement les dispositions
additionnelles à la corde commerce et de
coopération qui a été possible ont été
très peu nombreuses un élément nouveau
en 2023 en février 2023 avec le cadre de
Windsor qui conduit à une certaine
détente c'est le problème la frontière
nord irlandaise qui
des progrès ont été faits comme un
accord sans revenir sur
l'essentiel des dispositions mais des
facilités ont été mises en place ce qui
débloque un certain nombre de choses et
aujourd'hui même est signé à Bruxelles
un mémorandum understand standing sur
les questions de régulation financière
alors c'est pas des décisions c'est un
forum de discussion qui est mise en
place mais enfin c'est important il
n'existait pas on sent que il y a la des
possibilités de nouvelles coopération
deuxième dynamique à prendre en compte
c'est que côté européen ça bouge aussi
il y a des évolutions de la
réglementation européenne qui imposent
des décisions des traitements et c'est
ce nouveau contrôle aux frontières
Schengen ce nouveau dispositif
informatique qui est en cours de de
finition le calendrier qui est en cours
de révision nous attendions une décision
conseil justice à faire intérieure de
joint qui a été repoussé à septembre
le déploiement initialement prévu était
vu l'état de
discussions
il est possible que le déploiement est
plutôt lieu dans le courant de l'année
2024 en tout cas le sujet c'est que les
contrôles supplémentaires liés aux
données biométriques sont susceptibles
d'entraîner des risques d'augmentation
d'attente si les questions
d'organisation ne sont pas traitées
suffisamment en amont d'où notre
recommandation de finaliser des accords
avec les opérateurs en France et puis
aussi sur les postes où il y a des des
agents de des pays voisins enfin je
pense à ça Pancrace
il faut aussi des négociations avec le
Royaume-Uni sur certains de ses postes
front particuliers
et puis en matière douanière le système
de contrôle des importations va
connaître une nouvelle génération avec
des effets sur des points techniques
c'est tout ça n'est pas bloquant mais ça
suppose des négociations des discussions
avec les Britanniques donc il y a c'est
cette dynamique là qui est en fait
initié par les évolutions du côté
européen enfin troisième dynamique et là
nous nous appelons l'attention sur ce
point c'est ce sont les questions
d'évolution réglementaire les
Britanniques assument l'ambition de
divergence réglementaire s'est affiché
c'est assumé par le gouvernement
britannique c'est en train d'être
traduit en particulier dans leur
dans leur dispositif dans leur droit
britannique avec une loi qui prévoit des
clauses d'extinction automatique de lois
européennes
enfin en tout cas des dispositions
juridiques européenne alors certes c'est
cette liberté
est encadrée en tout cas il y a certains
accords internationaux qui qui en cas de
cette liberté l'accord de commerce et de
coopération avec l'Union européenne
comprend toute une série de dispositions
pour préserver des conditions de
concurrence équitables c'est ce thème du
level playing field mes enfants il faut
rester très vigilant parce que les
initiatives britanniques sont là
création de port francs modification du
dispositif de subventions les règles de
marché public la réglementation du
secteur financier la City est pleine
d'idées
sur un certain nombre de réglementations
des contraintes de bilan par exemple
avec le 26 ce genre de choses le
gouvernement britannique prend des
initiatives pour soutenir des secteurs
prioritaires les technologies émergentes
les
il y a des thèmes de protection de
données personnelles dans le domaine des
communications il y a toute une série de
points d'attention et en fait c'est ça
notre message
l'administration suit tout ça
n'est pas n'est pas absentes le
dispositif existe chaque ministère est
présent dans ses affaires-là mais notre
recommandation s'est dit il faut garder
la vue d'ensemble il faut garder la
dynamique et il faut être en capacité de
déterminer des vrais priorités ce que
les Britanniques ça fait et les
Britanniques ça va aller vite leur
dispositif juridique leur permet de
voter des lois plus vite qu'en France
s'il le souhaite et donc il faut rester
vigilant mieux identifier les effets de
moyen terme sur les principales
politiques publiques pour en déduire des
priorités d'action dans les instances de
décision à Bruxelles ou bien dans un
cadre bilatéral
d'où neuf recommandations
que je rappelle juste très rapidement
donc concernant la douane la frontière
alors il concerne pour l'essentiel
rétablissement de la frontière elles
sont sur des points
de gestion pour la douane des
indicateurs de suivi de l'ensemble des
contrôles un constaté que il y avait des
progrès en la matière n'a pas une vue
d'ensemble de l'ensemble des contrôles
d'en proposer de deux évolutions de leur
système informatique sur l'enveloppe
logistique et la mise à disposition de
données au service vétérinaires
s'agissant des services vétérinaires
c'est la question de l'adaptation
des plages horaires de l'organisation et
voir si
ce point si il est nécessaire d'aller
juste la reposer la question de
l'agrément pour les postes les moins
sollicités et la question de l'audit de
Boulogne sur la police aux frontières
c'est la question des pics de flux de
passagers
qui a retenu notre attention sous forme
de recommandation la collecte des droits
de chancellerie avec la nécessité de
déployer des termes de paiement
l'administration nous suit d'ailleurs
c'est en cours et nous recommandons de
conclure avec les gestionnaires
d'infrastructures des discussions sont
en cours on n'est pas on n'est pas au
tout début du processus mais nous
recommandons de finaliser cet accord ces
accords vu du déploiement du nouveau
système informatique Schengen enfin en
interministériel nous recommandons de
procéder à cette revue
interministérielle de dynamiques de
divergence réglementaires pour mieux
déterminer
nos priorités d'action voilà monsieur le
Président
l'essentiel de de ce travail et je
remercie encore les équipes de
guittersen qui a été
rapporteur importante cette enquête et
Françoise Bouillard qui a coordonné tout
cela comme contre rapporteur écoutez
merci beaucoup pour ce rapport que nous
avions déjà nous avions lu mais votre
présentation
synthétique et objective finalement mais
le doigt sur plusieurs points qui qui
ont fait l'objet de d'inquiétude ici
dans cette commission
je retiensdrais finalement en conclusion
vous avez dit quelque chose dans votre
propre éliminaire qui est important
c'est le brexit n'est pas fini et
effectivement nous on le constate le
brexit n'est pas fini sur plein de
sujets finalement
qui nous a animé ici notamment souvent
c'est celui de la pêche bien sûr et
celui de la renégociation de l'accord en
2026 qui est aujourd'hui un vrai sujet
d'inquiétude pour l'économie
au moins de trois régions je pense à la
Bretagne la Normandie et les hauts de
France
le deuxième point qui commence à nous
animer ici beaucoup et j'ai fait une
intervention il y a en commission des
finances sur le sujet c'est finalement
les 500 millions d'euros de la réserve
d'ajustements qui vont repasser sur un
autre budget hors contrôle parlementaire
finalement sans avis sans avis fine de
d'utilisation sur les territoires et les
territoires les plus concernés même si
le secrétariat général aux Affaires
européennes nous fait savoir que il y a
une discussion qui est entamée avec les
régions
mais on se dit finalement les dossiers
ont été tellement difficiles à monter et
tellement compliquée pour 200 millions
qui ne sont pas encore utilisés
est-ce que ça va pas en être autant pour
500 millions qu'il faudra utiliser
derrière avec des délais qui resteront
contraints un peu moins mais en tout cas
voilà donc on a perdu beaucoup de temps
je le sais on a perdu beaucoup de
négociation déjà avec l'Union européenne
pour obtenir les 700 les plus de 700
millions d'euros ça a été le premier
point et puis après on a perdu beaucoup
de temps alors que d'autres États
membres pendant la négociation comment
c'est déjà avancer sur le dispositif de
mise en place et je pense que nous on a
tardé dans le dispositif de mise en
place avec un flou et c'est je vous vois
au piné du chef donc ça veut dire que
vous avez expertisé la chose et vous
avez compris que c'était que c'était une
réalité
il y a un point aussi que je remarque
avant de vous poser une question plus
précise c'est sur le surcoût aux
entreprises privées du brexit 10% et je
pense que c'est là aussi où on pouvait
aller chercher une part des fonds
d'utilisation du brexit de du fond de de
réserve d'ajustement du brexit
et je crois que ça n'a pas été fait de
par la complexité des dossiers et dans
un dans une ETP vous savez pour monter
un dossier c'est quand même pas toujours
facile il y a pas de genre affectés et
là on a eu vraiment un problème dans
l'ingénierie du montage des dossiers et
l'explication c'est pour ça que je pense
qu'il aurait été beaucoup plus
intéressant à un certain moment de faire
comment le fait avec les fonds européens
en général c'est à dire de d'attribuer
une délégation beaucoup plus franche aux
régions avec une gestion de proximité
beaucoup plus importante et je crois que
là on aurait une utilisation des crédits
plus effective alors le problème
aujourd'hui c'est bien sûr le contrôle a
postériori qui fait que si
les fonds utilisés ne sont pas utilisés
finalement à bon escient reconnu comme
tel
l'état l'État membre et censé les les
rembourser et finalement les régions et
puis ensuite les attributaires de ces de
ces subventions donc je pense qu'il y a
effectivement et c'est bien que vous
vous pointiez la question un vrai
problème sur sur tout cela et sur les
500 millions à venir moi je vais être je
veux être très attentif sur ce qui va se
passer avec ces 500 millions qui restent
dans dans la caisse
ils font de l'ajustement du brexit une
question précise avant de laisser passer
la parole à mes collègues sur le S enfin
moi j'avais posé une question à la
ministre on a été sollicité pas mal de
fois notamment par les transporteurs
transmets
et du tunnel sous la Manche aussi
qu'est-ce qui fait que on arrive en
retard de calendrier parce que je pense
que ça fait deux fois que le calendrier
est un petit peu bougé sur cette sur
cette question c'est des problèmes
informatiques c'est des problèmes de
mise en place ou c'est simplement des
accords et des négociations
alors sur ce point vous savez que c'est
une c'est une structure européenne qui
porte ce projet elle est installé à
Strasbourg d'ailleurs même si des
équipes peuvent être dans plusieurs
autres pays et donc au point de départ
c'est cette structure européenne
coordonne la préparation technique du
système qui j'allais dire et
la force la plus importante dans les
questions de calendrier donc c'est cette
structure là qui avait recommandé
de mémoire au tout début de l'année 2023
ou à la fin de l'année 2022 qui avait
recommandé un décalage conduisant à un
avec une perspective à l'automne 2023
conduisant à une prise de décision
conseil justice à faire intérieure du
mois de juin
comme vous le savez ce conseil avait un
ordre du jour extrême en chargé et
sur d'autres questions
d'immigration en particulier et de fait
la décision a été repoussée au conseil
de justice à faire intérieur du mois de
septembre alors
à partir de là nous là nous n'avons pas
été
jusqu'à l'expertise
l'état des travaux au sein de la
structure européenne qui prépare la mise
au point technique donc là je
nous avons cru comprendre que c'est très
avancé on n'est pas on n'est pas du tout
dans une situation de début de processus
un Prost un projet qui a été engagé au
milieu des années 2010 2015 je crois les
toutes premières décisions donc on est
vraiment on s'approche de la phase de
mise au point final et déploiement
donc il faut attendre le conseil à faire
intérieur justice a fait intérieur du
mois de septembre
pour déterminer à quel moment ce système
informatique pourrait être déployé dans
les états donc dans les états Schengen
donc ça suppose une décision coordonnée
là je n'ai pas
je n'ai pas d'information mais en tout
cas dans les auditions auxquelles nous
avons procédé on ne parle pas 2025 2026
2027 à cause de difficultés
dans l'hypothèse la plus rapide ce sera
un déploiement fin 2017 fin 2023
dans une hypothèse un petit peu plus un
calendrier un peu plus détendu c'est
courant 2024
comprendre que du côté français il y
avait une attention particulière liée
aux Jeux Olympiques à l'été 2024 et il
faut être près de chez la question de
savoir si on introduit un nouveau
dispositif juste avant et Jeux
Olympiques peut-être une préoccupation
d'opportunités mais enfin
ce n'est pas un sujet en tout cas que
nous avons nous au cours des comptes
approfondis après et par rapport à votre
rapport et juste une remarque sur
l'hypothèse que vous émettez que les
structures notamment de contrôle
vétérinaire sont aujourd'hui peut-être
surdimensionnés par rapport à
quelle est la réalité des choses il faut
savoir enfin il y a une responsabilité
aussi de des élus qui ont poussé à
l'époque parce qu'on était vraiment dans
l'inconnu moi je l'ai vécu en direct
Matin Midi et Soir on ne savait pas ce
qui allait se passer en termes de
contrôle donc c'est pour ça que d'une
proposition ministérielle en est allé
plus loin en disant ces contrôles
doivent pouvoir se faire 24 heures sur
24 on savait vraiment pas on était dans
l'inconnu et surtout ce qu'on voulait
pas à l'époque c'était bloqué la place
de Boulogne notamment en termes de
transit du poisson je rappelle toujours
que cette plateforme en termes de
traitement du poisson c'est plus
important que Rungis donc c'était
impensable de pouvoir m'en bloquer cette
cette plateforme et donc c'est la raison
pour laquelle on est allé très loin
maintenant je pense que s'il y a des
réajustements à faire au regard de votre
rapport les gens comprendront mais mais
c'est vraiment la raison c'était
l'inconnu c'était l'inconnu
je vais demander à mes collègues s'ils
veulent poser des questions oui pierre
oui pour ce qu'est la sous-utilisation
des fonds de compensation
est-ce que la France n'est pas comme
toujours en fur réglementation et
notamment à travers l'utilisation de
fonds qui proviennent de l'Europe on
veut toujours être trop bordé
on n'applique pas seulement des règles
européennes on en ajoute tellement que
finalement les personnes concernées
renoncent purement et simplement parce
que remplir un dossier avec une
administration
hypertatillonne j'ai eu l'occasion
d'utiliser les fonds européens je puis
vous dire que l'administration
locale préfectoral régional
en rajoutant en permanence et ne connaît
pas les règles donc on en rajoute et on
refuse les dossiers sans savoir pourquoi
et j'ai eu tellement d'expérience de
démontrer au service administratifs
qu'il s'était dans le dans l'erreur
complète en demandant toujours plus et
je crains que ce soit une des raisons
essentielles qu'on retrouve d'ailleurs
pour un certain nombre de mesures
soutien aux entreprises qui ne demandent
pas parce que c'est tellement compliqué
alors en fait il y a deux éléments dans
votre intervention il y a
sur sur la réserve d'ajustement au
brexit
la première ministre dans sa réponse qui
qui est sur le site de la cour fait
valoir que
il y avait des contraintes de calendrier
il fallait qu'ils entreprises puissent
justifier des dépenses mais qui pouvait
être des dépenses
intervenues très vite en 2016 et en fait
avant que la période de référence prévue
par le règlement communautaire
permettent l'utilisation de ces crédits
communautaires donc il y avait une
question de calendrier et il y avait une
question de justification pour les
entreprises et pour les plus petites
d'entre elles qui est mise en avant
c'est que ces questions de
liées au règlement communautaire sont
mises en avant dans la réponse de la
première ministre comme un des éléments
ayant contribué à cette sous-utilisation
cela dit nos constats
comme vous l'avez dit l'administration a
mis du temps à se mettre à s'accorder
on peut pas citer tel ou tel direction
ou service mais
voilà donc je pense qu'il y a eu une
vraie question d'organisation
administrative française
pour la mise en oeuvre d'un règlement
qui effectivement comprenait comprenait
des contraintes spécifiques qui ont pu
qui peuvent peut-être expliquer une
partie de cette utilisation mais je
pense que une partie
une des difficultés c'est que
l'administration a pas su se vraiment se
coordonner suffisamment vite de notre
point de vue
je trouve que là la réponse de la
première ministre
la réponse de la première ministre et
suggère une crainte des administrations
de ne pas être en capacité de rendre
compte à posteriori du bon usage de ses
fonds toute la réponse est autour de
cela pour avoir été dans une vie
professionnelle antérieure gestionnaire
du Fond Social Européen je peux attester
que longtemps la France n'a pas été
organisée de façon suffisamment
performante pour rendre compte du bon
usage des crédits européens donc voilà
aujourd'hui on est à la phase numéro 2
où on a intériorisé cette crainte
peut-être de façon excessive il y a un
autre point je trouve plus troublant
dans la réponse de la première ministre
qui est de dire
que je vais essayer de retrouver la
phrase exacte enfin bon que c'était
assez complexe dans l'utilisation voilà
la constitution d'un dossier finalement
des incitatif pour nombre d'entreprises
parfois même insurmontable parce que les
dépenses mêlent liées au brexit se
mêlent aux dépenses qu'on sentit pour
faire face à la pandémie et là c'est
très troublant parce que justement on
attendait de la part des acteurs
français qu'ils aident les entreprises
dans ces démarches là elle fait le
constat de la difficulté sans prendre en
compte le fait que justement et c'est un
point soulevé par le rapport les
entreprises notamment les PME qui était
exportatrices vers le Royaume-Uni et
seulement vers le Royaume-Uni n'ont pas
été aidés dans leur démarche donc je
pense qu'à la fois la crainte au vu de
ce qui s'est passé
il y a quelques années et au vu des
corrections auxquelles la France a été
exposée et par ailleurs effectivement un
défaut d'organisation en soutien au PME
votre exemple du FSE et typique
effectivement il y a une période où
c'était compliqué de l'utiliser et en
plus il y avait beaucoup d'erreurs et à
un moment il y a eu des mesures de
simplification qui ont remis des choses
en ordre et oui il y a eu un bon usage
rapide du FSE alors qu'au départ on
renvoyait une partie du FSA Bruxelles
enfin j'ai connu cette période
complexité elle était pas seulement dû à
l'organisation française elle était
aussi due et il a une part aussi de la
complexité est due comme c'est très
largement développé dans la réponse de
la première ministre au règlement au
règlement lui-même alors là où on peut
s'interroger c'est sur le fait de ne pas
avoir vu avant que le règlement soit
finalisé qu'il était trop complexe c'est
ça qui est un peu ennuyeux dans le rôle
que nous jouons à Bruxelles mais que
d'autres pays jouent aussi procès-verbal
on peut peut-être ajouter que
pa tardif mais qui a gardé la complexité
inhérente ces dispositifs d'aide et je
pense que c'est un des facteurs qui a
conduit
attention sur une prochaine publication
et bien voilà
je me permets de d'ajouter un point sur
une prochaine publication de la cour sur
le budget de l'État le budget européen
et nous il y a toute une série de
développement sur la mise en œuvre des
programmes européens le la place des
programmes qui sont dans la main de la
commission si vous me permettez
plus comment dire qui prennent de plus
en plus de place avec des critères
spécifiques
nous vivons avec le plan de relance
européen un autre dispositif de suivi
avec des jalons avec des c'est une autre
logique sont structurelle j'allais dire
classique que tout le monde connaît
voilà nous avons analysé ça dans un dans
un rapport qui est
publié très très prochainement
juste aussi une petite remarque c'est
par rapport au finalement à
l'utilisation de ces fonds et du
transfert à la NCT de la compétence mais
à la NT est-ce qu'on a pas dû on a dû
recréer une administration propre pour
cette question je sais pas si la NTT
était aramé pour faire ce genre de
choses je vous ai dit mon sentiment fort
et ça n'est pas du chauvinisme de
conseiller régional mais je pense que on
était au plus proche avec les régions
pour gérer ses problèmes justement
d'entreprise parce qu'on connaît les
entreprises pour gérer les problèmes de
territoire parce qu'on connaît les
problèmes de territoire mais elle a NCT
il a fallu recréer une une
administration dont on me dit qu'elle
n'a pas été gratuite
alors je sais pas ça peut être
le point que vous soulevez de la NCT et
de la difficulté de coordination des oui
il y a eu des moyens la première
ministre rappelle dans sa réponse que 21
emplois ont été affectés pour tout cela
pour la gestion de la réserve mais bon
il y a eu un défaut de coordination
merci monsieur le Président tout d'abord
un grand merci à vous pour votre
présentation extrêmement claire et en
tant qu'élu dans le Pas-de-Calais nous
avons vécu de plein fouet j'ai envie de
dire avec toutes les craintes que vous
nous avons pu exprimer en tout cas ce
qui la suite en tout cas la sortie du
brexit
peut-être de questions la première
concernant le recrutement la main vous
avez évoqué l'ajustement nécessaire
notamment au sein des organisations pour
pouvoir mettre en place justement ce
brexit par contre nous n'avons pas
évoqué le volet ou l'impact en matière
de recrutement de main d'oeuvre
notamment dans le cadre de nos
entreprises nous en France est-ce qu'il
y a eu un impact on connaît tous les
difficultés en matière de recrutement
des entreprises dans tous les pays de
l'Union européenne est-ce que justement
ce brexit a eu un impact particulier sur
nos entreprises
ça c'est la première question qu'il a
deuxième vous avez évoqué aussi l'impact
en matière de commerce extérieur pour
notre pays et au bénéfice de quel autre
pays
est-ce que vous pourriez aussi nous
éclairer ou nous donner peut-être
davantage d'éléments sur ce point-là
merci
alors
nous n'avons pas de réponse globale en
vous disant voilà c'est ça un effet de
temps d'emploi sur les entreprises
françaises là on a pas on n'est pas en
capacité de faire ce genre de choses les
analyses très
il y a quelques chiffres très globaux
macroéconomiques
une autorité indépendante britannique
l'obéir l'Office of badge chrismans
estimé que à terme les faits en termes
d'échange extérieur se règle lors de
-15% sur l'économie britannique donc
c'est
potentiellement des effets
très important nous nous constatons sur
2021-2022 c'est le début c'est les
premiers effets donc on a une expression
prudente on n'a pas voulu généraliser
généraliser trop vite mais nous
constatons que ça a un effet sur nos
exportations et je crois qu'on peut dire
la question est-ce que finalement nos
exportateurs se redéploient vers
d'autres destinations mais je crois
qu'il faut des choses simplement les
tout petits exportateurs c'est fini
terminé ils vont plus sur le Royaume-Uni
alors jusqu'à quel point se sont-ils
redéployés vers d'autres destinations en
tout cas ça se fait pas en quinze jours
donc je crois que c'est un effet voilà
qu'il faut avoir à l'esprit alors à cela
s'ajoute en plus c'est difficile à
analyser il y a des affaires des
facteurs macroéconomiques des cycles
d'un pays à l'autre il y a des effets
changent qui peuvent être important il y
a
ce qui se passe sur le marché de
l'énergie qui vient polluer si vous me
permettez l'expression l'analyse des
chiffres du commerce extérieur donc tout
ça est assez difficile on ne peut pas
conclure avec des choses très globales
et très affirmative en tout cas ça va
bien dans le sens d'un effet sur sur les
entreprises françaises oui c'est pas
c'est pas neutre on ne on ne rétablit
pas des frontières sans que ça ait des
effets sur les échanges et donc sur les
entreprises
je vois pas d'autres questions je vais
vous en poser une dernière peut-être
en parlant de la jeunesse il y avait une
certaine appétence des étudiants
français pour aller au Royaume-Uni et
inversement du Royaume-Uni vers vers la
France vous l'avez exposé brièvement
dans le lien pour Hama que j'ai vu mais
on comprend bien qu'aujourd'hui qu'avec
des dispositifs qui étaient à la fois
accessible agréable et facilitant la
chose je pense à Erasmus aujourd'hui le
dispositif envers le Royaume-Uni
s'arrête c'est quels sont vos pistes en
fait pour permettre de retrouver à la
fois appétant cette facilité de d'accès
dans les échanges inter-universitaires
et dans la façon dont nos étudiants
pourraient continuer à aller travailler
au Royaume-Uni je pense notamment aux
aspects financiers
la place de Londres est finalement qu'on
disait morte avant le brexit et rester
tout aussi active en termes financier et
donc je pense qu'il voilà il faut
peut-être recréer cette appétence et il
faut il faut qu'on trouve des pistes en
fait pour pour permettre à ces jeunes de
d'aller au Royaume-Uni faire leurs
études
alors là vous vous donnez la réponse
vous donnez un programme d'action ça
serait aller un petit peu au-delà de ce
que nous pouvons faire en tout cas comme
je l'ai dit ce qu'on a constaté c'est
que c'est suffisamment sérieux pour que
ça a été un point du sommet bilatéral il
y en avait pas eu de puissance et c'est
ce sujet-là en vitesse à l'ordre du jour
et les deux gouvernements sont accordés
pour mettre en place un dispositif
permettant justement de de mieux
comprendre ce qui se passe et de voir
quelles conséquences en tirer donc là
c'est une approche bilatérale qui sur
ces sujets là et privilégié alors après
sur les programmes Erasmus l'ouverture
[Musique]
comment dire aux sites webitaniques là
la je n'ai pas le tout dernier état
d'information des
sur ces éventuels initiatives au niveau
communautaire là je ne serai pas
répondre précisément sur ce point
ajouter un
point parce que sur cet aspect enfin il
y a
cet aspect résulte en large partie de la
volonté des Britanniques
de montrer que il y avait un
avant-brexit et un après brexit avec des
décisions qui qui vu qui peuvent
paraître absurdes par exemple je sais
pas si on a rappelé dans le rapport on a
regardé pour le statut des opère jeune
fille
aujourd'hui
un Européen à français ou français ne
peut pas aller avec ce statut
Royaume-Uni alors que c'est autorisé un
Coréen un ressortissant de son marin
donc c'est les Britanniques qui fixent
la liste des pays et
ils ont voulu tenir alors ils se sont
auto punis mais ils ont voulu c'est une
certaine façon marquée le fait que
les Européens étaient
voilà devait être mis à l'écart donc il
y a plein de
beaucoup de sujets sur les vies
Jean-Pierre laboureix la rappeler là
encore les
les éléments de de décrypage de la
situation sans dans les mains
britanniques
Erasmus et ce sont les Britanniques qui
ont souhaité sortir du programme donc là
on est dans un élément c'est des gestes
de rupture voilà c'est des zestes de
rupture plus symboliques réelles enfin
même si pour les jeunes effectivement il
y a tous les niveaux alors il y a aussi
des voyages scolaires parce qu'ils font
un passeport dorénavant dans les dans
les classes vous le savez il y a aussi
le tourisme mémoire enfin voilà donc il
y a toute une série de choses qui
relèvent globalement d'un retour alors
que nous on affiche la souplesse
était au niveau européen il y a des
dispositifs je pense que nous on n'a pas
de difficultés pour pour accueillir
après il y a des sujets de réciprocité
quoi mais je pense que c'est pour ça que
le sommet franco-britannique était
important et aussi des décisions au
niveau européenne je pense que voilà il
y a une il y a vraiment une question de
bonne volonté britannique et d'en finir
avec l'idée on va montrer que nos
muscles en tapant sur les jeunes filles
au Père pour ce qui paraît un peu
absurde
écoutez merci titre question
je n'en vois pas
écoutez comme vous nous avez dit
qu'effectivement le brexit était pas
fini je suppose que il y aura d'autres
rapports sur sur le sujet et
de nouveaux points d'actualité mais en
tout cas merci de merci de ce travail
qui nous sert
sachez que voilà ça ne reste pas sans
voix et les opportunités qu'on peut
retrouver en particulier dans nos
régions sont importantes à cibler merci
beaucoup